– So!
– Bist du schon fertig?
– Jepp.
Ich geh morgen in die Druckerei,
um mir ’n Angebot machen zu lassen.
– Prima, dann kannst
du ab morgen wieder putzen.
Mit Lisa kann man ja
in diesem Jahr nicht rechnen.
– Habt ihr euch immer
noch nicht versöhnt?
– Wie denn?
– Nico! Das ist ja jetzt schön.
Jetzt sind alle zusammen.
Dann kann ich ’n Vorschlag machen.
– Ich muss Deutsch lernen.
– Wunderbar,
hier geht gleich einer in die Luft.
– Wie ist denn dein Vorschlag?
– Also: Offensichtlich hat
niemand Zeit für Hausarbeit.
– Niemand?
– Ja, zumindest
nicht alle gleich viel.
Ich finde, wir sollten uns einen Saugroboter
kaufen, um uns die Arbeit zu sparen.
– Einen Saugroboter?
– Ja. Der ist zwar wahnsinnig teuer, aber wir
können den Preis durch vier teilen.
Ich finde, wir sollten investieren,
damit die Stimmung wieder besser wird.
– Also ich finde, wir haben hier
schon genug Roboter in der WG.
– Mann, Nina, es reicht!
Und das mit dem Saugroboter ist
eine total blöde Idee.
– Du hast ihn dir noch nicht mal angeschaut.
Dann mach doch bitte einen
besseren Vorschlag, junge Frau.
– Mein Vorschlag ist, dass ich jetzt
das Bad putze und du die Küche.
– Okay. Sind wir denn offen für eine
Diskussion über Wischroboter?
– Erwartet ihr jemanden?